there are a lot of people talking about
the fake gurus right now and I for one
love it you have super talented
youtubers like Mike win it yep
spins are winning it you have I mean a
bunch of youtubers tons of people have
done videos about this by now why these
gurus fake gurus online fake guru fake
gurus these are some fake gurus you know
and I for one I welcome it I want people
to realize that there's no shortcut to
success but if you're gonna come into my
house okay if you're gonna come into the
fake guru dojo you better be ready to
talk to seafood
you better be ready to be caught out if
what you're doing is it right we've
already done this with Graham Stephan's
take on fake gurus but now we have
another challenger and this is gonna be
our toughest opponent yet Chris Hansen
let you take a seat right over there you
are me right the legendary journalist
Chris Hansen from to catch a predator I
have looked up to this guy forever he's
an amazing investigative reporter and
nothing in this show will take away from
that but he he stepped in he stepped
into the fray stepped into the Coliseum
and as such you know look I've got a pop
because he released a video
investigating work at home scams
this is scam report now there's a lot of
this I agree with he talks about how the
new economy has created more scams than
ever but the new economy has also
spawned a new breed of criminal looking
to make a quick buck at your expense he
talks about how these scams are getting
more sophisticated and harder to spot
some scams are glaringly obvious but the
worst ones are getting more
sophisticated all the time and he talks
about the importance of doing your due
diligence it's hard to overemphasize the
importance of research when embarking on
a work at home business and I have no
problem with any of this but then he
decides we're gonna introduce someone
else to the equation
someone who operates a legitimate work
at home business scheme he used the
Internet to build a hugely successful
business
the Internet is a place where many
people make a lot of money is it really
just a matter of discipline I'd always
told myself I was gonna be an
entrepreneur I was trying to make money
on the internet for years I mean I spent
four years I didn't make a dime and I
was just trying and trying and trying I
didn't make anything just because it's
marketed as as free and easy and it can
make you know a ton of money don't just
fall for any shiny object that's thrown
your way who waste this man this
legitimate businessman for every single
successful way to make money as an
entrepreneur on the Internet there are a
hundred ways to get ripped off 100% 100%
it's John Chris Donnie there are more
scams out there on the internet than
there are legitimate opportunities by
far okay let me try to explain what this
is like let me put it in Chris hands in
terms imagine Chris Hansen created a
show called to spot a predator but then
he invites a predator on the show to
explain how to spot a predator that's
how ridiculous this is John crostini has
been featured on the show many times
we've debated we've done a bunch of
shows I'll put a few links in the
description where you could watch how
we've covered them in the past our
public debate together but this guy is
not some squeaky-clean work-from-home
guy okay let's check out this method to
literally copy-paste ads to make money
first off you don't want to run a
business where you have to actually like
buy products and like ship them out to
people you don't want to have to do any
work for it search for my last name
because the product we're gonna be
selling is actually my product it's your
kid on this get your five-year-old on
this I'd like to introduce you to my
friend Benjamin and his friend Benjamin
and his friend Benjamin there are more
scams out there
the Internet then there are legitimate
opportunities by our and he's posing is
like the spotter the expert even wrote
he wrote a book about it and he's
selling that book on the video I mean
this could be your opportunity to work
from home like Chris Hansen is selling
the book by now you might be wondering
if a home-based business is the
financial answer you've been looking for
to learn more and to reserve your copy
of John Chris Tommy's book use the work
at home hotline information you see on
your screen below and suddenly you
realize that wait this isn't an
investigation this is an infomercial in
fact John crostata calls it an
infomercial for his product now that's
weird because it's pitched as a report
and an investigation it's supposed to be
about work work at home job scams
this is scam report but the end you find
out that the whole thing is sponsored by
Pendragon Labs sponsored by Pendragon
labs the company that john chris donnie
owns so john chris oh my gosh it's so
it's amazing it's amazing
so basically John Chris Donnie hired
Chris Hanson to make a video about work
at home job scams in which he puts
himself as the expert that will explain
how to spot a work at home job scam but
the entire thing is a pitch for his book
which is not actually a $1.00 book like
he says it is because it's a $39 a month
subscription feed that you're signing up
for when you get the buck so
so the irony is amazing because Chris
Hansen he's supposedly investigating
this
well actually just pitching a scam
because buying a book that ultimately
signed you up for a $40 a month
subscription fee is that a scam I would
say so looks normally cost 10 bucks they
don't have a $40 subscription fee
attached to it and it's amazing guys
it's amazing because the stuff John Besh
Donnie says of like how you can spot a
scam directly corresponds to his actual
advertising on his own website look at
this just because it's marketed as as
free and easy and it can make you know a
ton of money don't just fall for any
shiny object that's thrown your way so I
don't know I kind of want to hear from
you guys do you think Chris Hanson knew
is is he just kind of ignorant of who
John crostini is let me know in the
comments below and you know as usual
guys don't forget to smash like and
subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]
or the car
[Music]